think that child that was going to be  born because like the life that is going  to live do you think it's going to live  a good life and then isn't that isn't  that actually being cruel to this child  that would be born my question is do you  believe that poor children are less  valuable they're not less valuable  they're just not going to have a good  value of life so why should that why  should they why should I put a child on  this Earth that's gonna not not have a  good quality when I could do it give it  a good quality of life when I'm prepared  in the future quality of life I have two  things one the majority of abortions are  with women that make over forty seven  thousand dollars per year so it's not an  income thing only only eight percent of  women  today I don't I don't when you're firing  back at these facts I don't they don't  mean anything  47 grand a year like do you earn that